what's going on guys this is rob and
i've been in this youtube game for
something like seven
years i think or at least coming up on
seven years i think it's like six and a
half years now
and i want to try something that i've
never done before that i've never ever
ever done before
and i think this is a cool idea right so
um whether it's been through social
media posts like twitter or instagram or
something like that
or emails that you guys have sent me or
or questions in the discord server
a lot of you guys seem to have expressed
this desire to be able to talk to me or
talk to each other
while you're watching my videos in real
time and
that can be done that is the thing that
we're going to try so the way this is
going to work is starting tomorrow at
8am august 17th at 8am
um we are going to fire up the twitch.tv
comics explained channel and we are
going to run this channel non-stop
right we're going to run through all the
character explanations that i have
then we're going to run through all the
full story videos that i have and
it's going to be just back to back to
back to back to back right so the stream
will not go
offline and and i want to hang out with
you guys and i want to talk to you guys
and what i'll probably do is give you
guys some stuff right just give stuff
away for free so i'll probably give away
some rob core rings
give away like some trade paperbacks
right just saying like what trade
a trade paperback do you want and then
just send it to you right we'll probably
end up doing that
i'm just kind of giving away some free
stuff uh but the twitch stream is for
the most part all set up right all we
have to do is just hit
start so unless we run into some kind of
technical error which as far as i'm
aware we won't we've already kind of
gone through everything we've tested the
stream
it works fine um then then we should we
should be ready to go
right by like tomorrow so i'm excited at
this i'm excited at this idea of being
able to just
fire my videos up non-stop and watch
them with you guys and talk to you guys
and hang out because i'll probably throw
some tidbits of like little facts and
stuff in there right like with the very
early videos that i did
compared to like how i have a lot more
of my personality in my videos now
um i think it's cool and i think it's
really exciting so if you guys
are down for this if you guys are down
for for hanging out with me
for watching these videos if you guys
are down for being part of like
a 24 hour live stream like just live
streaming around the clock and just
never stopping
watching comics explained videos anytime
you want to uh then make sure you guys
check the link down in the description
right if you want to win some free stuff
make sure you guys check the link down
in the description uh yeah i think it'll
be awesome
i think it'll be cool so i'm very
excited for this so i guess i will see
you guys
tomorrow i might i'll probably be in
there around like 9 30 or 10
um because i'm usually up by 5 30 and
then i gotta you know get my breakfast
and then go to the gym
and then once i get back i've cleared my
whole day i have nothing going on
i'm just hanging out and talking to you
guys so that'll be
cool but yeah so uh so
i'm nervous to be honest with you guys
i'm kind of nervous i'm nervous i've
never done this before
uh i'm nervous about this but it's gonna
be fun and it's gonna be awesome
so uh yeah i will see you all tomorrow
morning
peace